-Listen to this.
A new coffee shop just opened
in Seattle called
DreamBoyz Espresso,
where all the baristas
are buff, shirtless guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Best part is you can order
your coffee tall, grande,
or Magic Mike XXL.
It's great.
-Oh, oh, Jimmy,
Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Colin, Michael Che.
-Jimmy.
-What's up?
-What's going on?
-A coffee shop
with shirtless baristas
and that's the best you got,
really?
-Tell him, Che.
[ Laughter ]
-Jost, Che, what?
You guys you think you can do
better than that?
-Oh, we know we can. Probably.
-Well, you know what that means?
It is time for a good
old-fashioned
"Tonight Show" joke-off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think we all know the rules.
One more time, a new coffee shop
just opened in Seattle
called DreamBoyz Espresso,
where all the baristas
are buff, shirtless guys.
And go.
-Beep, beep, beep.
It's 3 bucks for a coffee
and 50 bucks for them
to grind your bean.
-Alright, that's good,
that's good.
Meep.
Shirtless baristas --
This is great news for everyone
who wishes the strip club
played more Norah Jones.
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Beep, beep, beep!
Trust me.
You don't want to see how
they draw a heart in your foam.
[ Laughter ]
-Eh!
Every customer was like,
"I'll take one cup of Joe-y."
-Beep.
-All the baristas
are buff, shirtless guys?
"I can't wait to check it out,"
said the health inspector.
[ Laughter ]
-Beep, beep, beep!
-Said Colin, "Please don't tell
Scarlett you saw me here."
[ Laughter ]
-Eh!
The Wi-Fi password
is bow-chicka-wow-wow
underscore 69.
-Beep!
But I don't recommend this place
if you have a nut allergy.
-Oh! Stop, stop, stop, stop.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, alright,
alright, alright.
-Kids are watching this.
-I'll give you that one.
I'll give you that one.
Alright, here's the next story.
Several big alcohol companies
say they're working on
developing drinkable marijuana.
And go.
-Oh, beep!
And somehow it still gives you
cotton mouth.
-Beep, beep, beep.
Of course,
all marijuana is drinkable
when the cops pull you over.
-Eh!
Meanwhile, Natural Ice said
they're still trying to
develop drinkable beer.
-Beep, beep!
They even got a catchy name for
it -- Snoop Dogg's Urine.
[ Laughter ]
-Beep, beep, beep.
If you want to know what
drinkable marijuana tastes like,
just take a sip out of Che's mug
right now.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll give him that one.
-It's for my glaucoma.
-Oh, you have glaucoma?
-Glaucoma, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Helps him read, yeah.
-Alright, Jost,
you got that one.
Alright, last story here.
Iggy Azalea says her upcoming
shows will have a twerk pit.
Go.
-Beep, beep.
As in "I entered the twerk pit
and nine months later,
you were born."
-Beep, beep, beep!
That's insane.
Iggy Azalea has upcoming shows?
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
-Wow.
-Alright, well, it's a twerk
pit, twerk pit, alright.
Eh! Fans were like, "Of course,
the person with the tallest ass
is right in front of me."
-Beep, beep!
A twerk pit sounds cool,
but I bet it smells terrible.
[ Laughter ]
-Beep, beep, beep.
Okay, sure, right.
But when I started twerk pit,
I'm banned from Chuck E' Cheese.
-Yeah.
Eh!
So, if you hear people clapping,
that's not hands.
There you are, everybody!
-Colin Jost, Michael Che,
everybody!
Thank you, guys.